bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 15 février primes d'assurance-vie
doublé pour les enfants handicapés
mentaux le groupe axa confirme et
renvoie l'état l'idée de la solidarité
la nouvelle répartition des enseignants
prévue par la carte scolaire de la
rentrée 2000 provoque une série de
mécontentements dans plusieurs académies
avec occupations d'écoles les
manifestations à flavin dans l'aveyron
les gendarmes cherchent à percer le
mystère des meurtres commis hier matin
outre les deux morts un enfant d'amour
reste introuvable
la gestion de son compte en banque via
internet suscite encore la méfiance des
clients français méfiance du à la
fragilité de sécurité de ses banques en
ligne au cinéma demain sur les écrans
français un nouveau film d'ettore scola
le dîner tout se passe dans un
restaurant donc fanny ardant qui nous
fait l'honneur d'être invité ce soir et
l'hôtesse la chose est dit clairement
par le groupe d'assurances axa ce n'est
pas un assureur privé de jouer la
solidarité mais à l'état cette phrase
est une sorte de réponse à ceux qui se
sont étonnés comme le révélait ce matin
journal l'humanité du doublement du
montant des primes d'assurance vie des
parents d'enfants handicapés mentaux
ceux ci paient chaque trimestre une
prime qui sera versée à leur décès à
leur enfant sous forme d'une rente à vie
mais pour l'assureur axa ce type de
contrat est devenue déficitaire
enquête sophie mais el hadj moustapha et
michel levasseur
la nouvelle a du mal à passer il ya de
quoi quand il y à 12 ans les perez ont
signé ce contrat
il pensait à leur fils à ce qui lui
arriverait après leur mort
guy 41 ans a toujours été un enfant
différent retardé comme on dit
aujourd'hui levier à la maison mais
après après ses parents comptait sur
cette rente viagère une petite somme
mensuelle qui doit s'ajouter aux
allocations versées par l'état
mais le contrat signé auprès de l'ua
paix qui a été entre-temps absorbé par
axa n'est plus rentable
la durée de vie des handicapés s'est
allongée le nombre des cotisants s'est
réduit l'équation est presque trop
simple
à présent nous ne pouvons pas continuer
de cette façon il est hors de question
pour axa de modifier le montant de la
cotisation pour faire un profit
quelconque
nous n'avons pas l'intention de faire un
franc de profits sur ce contrat mais il
est absolument indispensable de pour la
préservation même de ce contrat de le ré
équilibrer financièrement seule issue
proposé par l'assureur
un doublement de la prime ainsi pour une
pension annuelle de 37 mille quatre cent
quarante francs versés à leur fils après
leur décès la cotisation d.perez
passerait de 14000 392 francs à plus de
28 mille francs par an le fait de
doubler
c'est pour nous pousser à laisser tomber
vraiment poussé par force
et alors donc ils encaissent cet argent
et nous donne rien et nous ont vendu du
vent moi je trouve ça aberrant
le contrat d'assurance survie n'accepte
plus de nouveaux adhérents - l'argent
rentre dans les caisses - il y en aura à
répartir alors demain comment payer ses
rentes viagères les primes pourraient
bien être multiplié par dix pas question
d'accepter la carte scolaire telle
qu'elle est présentée par le ministère
de l'éducation via les recteurs
d'académie
si l'on en juge par la multiplication
des manifestations et occupations
d'écoles depuis plusieurs jours les
suppressions des postes d'enseignants
annoncées ou bien la faiblesse des
emplois créés selon les parents d'élèves
ou les syndicats de professeurs me brise
un peu partout mais surtout dans le
département de l'hérault et du gard
commentaires elsa nargue
même de grève les enseignants de
l'hérault ont passé la vitesse
supérieure péages d'autoroute bloqué 40
% d'instituteur en grève et des noms
d'oiseaux qui vole en direction du
recteur d'académie
c'est un vecteur mais c'est aussi un
rigolo et ne connaît pas ses dossiers
donc j'espère que pendant les quinze
jours de vacances il va réviser son
dossier
les départements de l'hérault et du gard
réclame 650 postes supplémentaires
l'académie laurent promet 78 alors pour
clamer leur désaccord parents d'élèves
et enseignants occupent près de 200
écoles depuis plusieurs jours même
ambiance dans les académies de lyon
rennes ou nantes
cette école primaire s'est mobilisée
pour conserver deux instituteurs car ici
chaque sauveteur qu'on pense qu'on va
retrouver l'écart se réduit tout 29
peluche malheureusement la fausse note
aussi sur l'académie de toulouse la
haute garonne et pourtant bien doté avec
85 postes supplémentaires mais en
contrepartie les écoles rurales de
l'aveyron du tarn des hautes-pyrénées
perdront des enseignants septembre
prochain pour sa rentrée 2000 claude
allègre est décidément à contretemps
dans la grande valse des effectifs la
pollution du bassin du danube par le
cyanure est très limité selon les
autorités roumaines et nous n'en sommes
pas responsables ajoutent les dirigeants
la compagnie australienne esmeralda co
propriétaire de la mine d'or à l'origine
de cette pollution
en revanche des experts écologistes ou
bien encore la commission européenne
parle d'un accident écologique
considérable qui empoisonne la faune et
la flore du danube depuis la roumanie
jusqu'à la yougoslavie en passant par la
hongrie commentaires louis carzou par
charrettes entières des aloses des
esturgeons des cartes des affronts pas
une espèce n'est épargné par le cyanure
plus de 100 tonnes de poissons
empoisonné ont déjà été retirés de la
tisza et du danube
alors faute de pouvoir intervenir sur la
faune aquatique
on essaye de sauver ce qui peut encore
l'être comme les rapaces qui se
nourrissent du fleuve et risquent eux
aussi de son président et cette
catastrophe frappe tous ceux qui vivent
du fleuve
surtout dans la région de la tis on va
mettre 20 ans à s'en relever
au total ce sont quelque cent mille
mètres cubes d'eau contaminée au cyanure
qui se sont échappés de cette mine de
rôle un senior utilisé pour séparer l'or
des autres minerais un cyanure presque
innocent comme de l'eau claire selon les
exploitants du site qui ne veulent
reconnaître qu un effet médiatique
encore une fois on ne peut pas parler
d'un désastre écologique majeure il y
aura peut-être quelques effets mais il
faut attendre le verdict des experts
pour les experts des organisations
écologistes c'est bel et bien un
désastre un désastre d'autant plus grave
qu'il était prévisible
lundi dans l'aude à lui à l'andalousie
en 1998 à la suite duquel le wwf a remis
un rapport en 1999 à la commission
européenne disant que les bassins de
stockage de ce type était dangereux ce
soir la pollution continue de progresser
à travers la roumanie vers la bulgarie
et pour plusieurs centaines de milliers
de personnes au coeur de l'europe
l'eau potable est devenu une ressource
en danger mais groupe minier qui
produisent de leurs utilisent tous le
cyanure pour des raisons de rentabilité
et l'accident sur le site roumain n'est
pas le premier du genre on cite
notamment deux cas semblables 7 au mois
d'août 95 en guyane et en mai 98
kirghizstan en france nous vous le
révélions dès hier dans cette édition
plus d'une centaine de sites sont
répertoriés officiellement comme
contenant de l'arsenic ou du cyanure
dans la creuse il ya un an de bovins
sont morts après être venu paître sur
les terrils de la mine d'or du châtelet
ses terres ils sont chargés d'arsenic et
le cyanure le site est classé dans le
ministère de l'environnement et doit
faire l'objet d'une procédure de
réhabilitation en cap christophe devals
en bras et alain darrigand une montagne
de déchets miniers dont un jour on a
extrait de l'or 500 mille tonnes de
terre et des restes de produits
chimiques mortels de l'arsenic surtout
plusieurs milliers de tonnes en 1955
cette mine d'or ferme ses portes le site
est abandonné et puis il ya deux ans un
troupeau de vaches y pénètre deux décède
empoisonné à l'arsenic
le préfet de la creuse henri ferrals a
tout de suite pris l'affairé en main a
alerté les pouvoirs publics et quelques
mois après nous avons nous avons appris
je dirais avec plaisir qu'une enveloppe
du ministère de l'environnement étaient
disponibles pour dépolluer ce site est
tout de suite la procédure a été entamée
des mesures d'urgence le site est
immédiatement interdit au public par
arrêté préfectoral
mais l'installation des clôtures a
débuté il ya un mois à peine plus d'un
an après l'accident une lenteur à
l'image du délai qu'il a fallu à l'état
pour pouvoir agir légalement sur ce site
il y a dix ans il a d'abord fallu en
retrouver le propriétaire la société qui
exploitait la mine
seuls responsables de la dépollution
elle est en procédure de liquidation
judiciaire
alors il faut attendre fin 98 pour que
l'état puisse enfin déclaré le site
orphelin et agir le syndic de
liquidation à avec les fonds dont ils
disposaient à fait quelques études et il
ya deux ans le sadique nous a dit j'ai
puisé totalement tous les fonds donc
dans ce cas là dans ce cas là le cdta
qui se substitue à l'ancien exploitant
et qui confie l ademe les travaux de
réhabilitation
l'ademe l'agencé de l'environnement et
de la maîtrise de l'énergie qui doit
encore mettre en place et les travaux de
réhabilitation
nous allons inerte et tous les déchets
les plus dangereux bien les les stocker
dans du béton céramique et mener
différents travaux de terrassement pour
éviter toutes les circulations nos vers
la rivière il aura donc fallu presque 50
ans pour que l'arsenic de la mine d'or
du châtelet ne soit plus un danger il
n'y était c'est rendre inertes en
matière de sécurité du transport
maritime deux mois après le naufrage du
pétrolier erika le premier ministre lien
jospin a évoqué aujourd'hui les
propositions françaises de renforcement
des contrôles
reportage évitant des règles jacques
kaprièlian
entre quinze et seize mille tonnes de
fuel se sont déjà échappées de l'erika
le tout dernier bilan fourni hier par le
ministère de l'environnement est encore
revu à la hausse
plus jamais ça on connaissait le mot
d'ordre du gouvernement aujourd'hui
lionel jospin annonce et les moyens
qu'il compte déployer pour y parvenir
la france va donc faire des propositions
pour la sécurité maritime pour tenter de
l'améliorer en tout cas face à
l'explosion du trafic et face au
pavillon de complaisance toujours plus
nombreux premier objectif la prévention
tous les navires transportant des
matières dangereuses aurait désormais
obligation de se signaler à la proche
des côtes d'un pays de l'union
européenne pour entrer dans un port
européen s'est même navire devrait
obtenir une autorisation spécifique
surveillance inspections renforcées des
bateaux interdiction de certains navires
c'est le deuxième volet annoncé
aujourd'hui en matière de contrôle la
france propose à partir de 2008 de
refuser l'accès au bateau n'ayant pas de
double coque
la date initialement prévue était 2019
face au désastre de la marée noire que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités c'est
le troisième axe sur lequel le
gouvernement s'engage les armateurs
seront davantage impliqués mais les
responsables ce sont aussi les états
chaque pays de l'union européenne est
appelée à mettre en commun ses
informations sur les bateaux à risque
enfin la france suggère de taxer les
importations d'hydrocarbures venant de
pays susceptibles d'utiliser des navires
en mauvais état toutes ces propositions
doivent maintenant recevoir l'aval
européen mais la france va justement
présidé l'union à partir du mois de
juillet lionel jospin entendait prendre
l'initiative sur le littoral atlantique
les rochers les plages du morbihan et de
la loire atlantique et de la vendée ne
sont pas encore nous nettoyer loin s'en
faut cent seize mille tonnes de déchets
ont déjà été ramassés
on entre maintenant dans une deuxième
phase de dépollution celle qui consiste
à remettre en état les sites utilisés
provisoirement pour stocker les déchets
pollués première opération à
saint-michel-chef-chef 7 en
loire-atlantique commentaires thomas
dandois avec la collaboration de
confrères de france trop nantes
c'était le rendez vous les amateurs de
pétanque mais la marée noire a fait de
ce boulodrome un site de près stockage
ici pendant plusieurs semaines 1200
tonnes de fuel récupérés sur les plages
ont été entreposés depuis hier les
équipes de la dde tente de rendre à ce
terrain sa vocation d'origine
ils font un 40 âge tu avais un jour un
trou il enlève de la terre il l'analyse
et puis si jamais la terre est polluée
et bien les engins vous voyez derrière
nous vont enlever à nouveau la terre
jusqu'à ce que la terre on trouve de la
terre non polluée mais pour ce militant
écologiste
il est déjà trop tard le ruisseau situé
à proximité du site a été contaminé le
ruisseau est d'ores et déjà polluée on
l'a vu particulièrement les jours de
pluie ou les résidus de pétrole était
emmenée par la pluie dans la petite
rivière s'était plaint d'irisation tout
le monde pouvait le voir sur 300
kilomètres de littoral atlantique
on compte 28 sites de stockage
provisoire ils s'échelonnent de
belle-ile à la rochelle avec une forte
concentration en loire atlantique pour
la plupart ces sites ne sont plus en
activité mais sept d'entre eux reçoivent
toujours des déchets il s'agit de la
turballe base sur mer saint brevin la
plaine pornic à la bernerie et
fromentine chacun de ces terrains doit
être débarrassé de son bouderont et
dépollués ensuite les déchets seront
évacués vers des raffineries comme ici à
donges
en tout l'opération devrait durer quatre
mois et coûté entre 3 et 10 millions de
francs l'addition sera entièrement
réglée par total fina une procédure
d'infraction au droit européen dans le
cadre de la sphère de la vache folle a
été déclenchée par la commission
européenne contre l'allemagne après la
france la commission veut savoir
pourquoi en allemagne la levée de
l'embargo sur bob britannique n'est pas
appliquée la commission européenne qui
vient de lever l'immunité de l'ancien
commissaire edith cresson immunité
couvrant la période de janvier 95 70 99
cette décision fait suite à la demande
de la justice belge qui veut interroger
mme cresson sur l' embauche de l'un de
ses proches et discrétion avait
tellement souhaité pouvoir s'expliquer
afin que toute la vérité soit faite
vient-elle de dire reportage stéphane
breitner et valérie
il n'y a pas eu de suspense
depuis la fin de l'après midi edith
cresson n'est plus protégé par
l'immunité parlementaire
une levée d'immunité qu'elle avait
d'ailleurs demandé jeudi dernier
voici donc une première dans l'histoire
europe et il va de soi que la commission
ne se prononce nullement sur le bien
fondé des allégations dont fait état la
démarche du juge d'instruction ce juge
c'est jean claude van espen un belge
connu pour avoir instruit l'affairé
pineau valencienne
il va dorénavant pouvoir entend d'edith
cresson comme témoin dans deux affaires
de fraude dans lesquels le nom de
l'ancien commissaire européen paraît
c'était entre 95 et 99
lorsqu'elle était à la tête d'une
direction chargée de l'éducation et de
la recherche première enquête celle
concernant rené berthelot un ami proche
d'edith cresson
elle est soupçonnée d'avoir favorisé son
embauche à bruxelles
or on sait aujourd'hui qu'il était
chargé de mission à châtellerault la
justice belge s'interroge donc sur la
nature de son contrat et de son travail
le deuxième dossier concerne la gestion
d'un programme d'éducation baptisé
leonardo ce programme de formation des
jeunes étaient gérés par un bureau
d'assistance technique
là encore la justice s'interroge sur la
nature des prestations
c'est donc pas le principe même d'une
collaboration extérieure qui est en
cause c'est de savoir quel est l'objet
exact de ce type de prestation qui
pourrait ne pas être aussi transparents
qu'on voudrait il ya peut-être des
prestations fictives
c'est un élément qui seront en tout cas
l'objet de l'enquêté
en mars dernier ces deux enquêtes avait
provoqué la démission de la précédente
commission européenne edith cresson
attend maintenant la convocation du juge
elle qui a souhaité ce soir que toute la
vérité soit faite
condamnation à un an de prison ferme du
sénateur communiste jean luc becquaert
l'ancien maire d'auchel près de béthune
dans le pas-de-calais monsieur becca a
été reconnu coupable de faux d'abus de
confiance et d'atteinte à la législation
sur l'attribution des marchés publics
dans l'aveyron près de rodez jean cap
des gendarmes près le double meurtre
commis hier matin dans une maison de
flavin est confrontée à beaucoup
d'éléments mystérieux
femme et la fillette de 12 ans décédée
ont été tuées par balles quant au bébé
âgé d'un mois il n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé malgré toutes les recherches
aux alentours reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux tiret curtet et christian
galley deux heures ce matin deux heures
encore cet après midi le père à ferfay
expliqué ray expliqué devant les
gendarmes
ses premiers gestes au moment où il
découvre les corps de sa femme et de sa
fille il précise ainsi son trajet pour
ne pas qu'il soit confondue avec
d'autres empreintes ce soir l'autopsié a
révélé la seule certitude du dossier
morgan et manuela ont toutes deux été
tué d'une balle de petit calibre dans la
tête
aucune conclusion pour l'instant nous
sommes donc à la recherche du bébé ou
puisque comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure au dessus de plus en plus
pessimiste du corps de l'enfant de
larmes ou de toute arme qui pourrait
correspondre
nous avons vérifié les premières pistes
et surtout recherché dans un premier
temps le corps car le bébé du couple né
le 10 janvier dernier reste introuvable
l'espoir qu'il soit encore vivant
s'amenuisent les recherches pour diriger
vers les décharges publiques cet après
midi elles ont toutes été minutieusement
fouillés
deux plongeurs spéléologues mouvements
attendus ont exploré en toute fin
d'après-midi le puits de la maison rien
qui les intéressent toutes les
hypothèses de criminologie sont épuisés
les yeux après les autres dans ce petit
village de 2000 âmes on s'endort dans la
quiétude
ce soir pas de mobile pas de suspect
aucune piste officiellement pour
expliquer la mort d'une maman et d'une
petite fille ordinaire couple sans
histoire oui jamais eu de bons rapports
me disant que ce couple était qu'il y
avait une nécessité les mésententes
n'est pas que ce sens il faudra attendre
sans doute plusieurs jours encore pour
que les éléments examinés par la police
scientifique du dessinent de nouvelles
pistes
et puis dans cette région je signale la
nouvelle formule du journal centre
presse éditions publient aujourd'hui où
on évoque une scène de carnage à flavin
juste après la mort à la fin de la
semaine dernière des quatre randonneurs
dans les pyrénées atlantiques victime
d'un feu d'écobuage deux hommes ont
avoué aujourd'hui avoir allumé le feu
mais le procureur de la république de
bayonne se dit persuadée du caractère
accidentel de ce drame devant la cour
d'assises de paris c'était aujourd'hui
la fin du procès de mamadou traoré a
accusé de l'agression de six femmes dont
deux sont décédés l'accusé a toujours
expliqué avoir été envoûté son avocat a
demandé l'acquittement en estimant que
mamadou traoré n'était pas responsable
de ses actes mais le procureur avait
requis la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
il a été suivi dominique verdeilhan puis
le verdict est tombé il ya à peu près
une demi heure maintenant verdict sans
surprise réclusion cris
la perpétuité avec une période de sûreté
de 22 ans c'est le maximum prévu par la
loi d'un verdict sans surprise l'accusé
lui même ne semble pas avoir été étonné
par cette condamnation
vous l'avez dit son avocat avait plaidé
l'acquittement arguant que et bien
ensorcelé mamadou traoré n'était pas
pénalement responsable mais ce procès a
surtout été également pénible pour les
victimes qui tout au long de ces
audiences ont eu à essuyer l'arrogance
parfois la grossièreté de leur agresseur
et ce soir une des victimes des
survivantes violemment blessé frappé au
visage par mamadou traoré et qui
souffrent d'amnésie et bien a souhaité
réagir publiquement à l'énoncé sauvian
soulagé mais c'est celui j'attendais je
suis soulagé vêtements
qu'est ce que vous a apporté ce procès
permet de tourner la page et
de recommencer narrant commencé voilà
dernière précision mamadou traoré
pourrait être l'un des premiers
condamnés a bénéficié de l'appel aux
assises qui sera applicable à partir du
1er janvier 2001 qui pourrait être
appliqué à partir du 1er janvier 2001
mais qui aurait un effet rétroactif pour
tous ceux qui vont se pourvoir dans les
mois qui viennent en cassation
ainsi dominique à londres la haute cour
a ordonné que soient communiqués ou
quatre états espagne france belgique et
suisse est assez risqué l'extradition la
augusto pinochet le rapport médical
concernant l'ancien dictateur c'est sur
la foi de ce rapport comme mise
intérieur britannique avait conclu à
l'impossibilité de juger le général
cette décision l'a soulevé
l'enthousiasmé des personnes qui portent
plainte contre le général pinochet et
les crimes commis pendant sa dictature
l'armée républicaine irlandaise a choisi
de rompre tout contact dans les
négociations en cours depuis près de
trois mois sur son désarmement
l'ira a fait ce choix en raison de la
suspension par londres des institutions
nord-irlandaise demain à londres de
nouveaux entretiens auront lieu pour
tenter de résoudre la crise en irlande
du nord
à la cité du vatican le pape jean paul
ii a reçu aujourd'hui le président
palestinien yasser arafat
de part et d'autre on a qualifié
d'historique qu'un accord rédigé et
signé par l'autorité palestinenne
exotiques ans dans cet accord une
solution équitable pour jérusalem et un
statut spécial garanties internationales
menton la ville sont mentionnés ce qui
provoque ce soir une réaction critique
du gouvernement israélien réalisme ou
coïncidence choquante la russie vient
d'obtenir une remise de dette importante
pour ces échanges commerciaux la russie
responsable de la guerre en tchétchénie
où les témoignages se succèdent
exactions commises par l'armée de camps
où sont pratiquées des civils et des
tortures voir des exécutions et vladimir
poutine qui vient de se déclarer
officiellement candidat aux prochaines
élections présidentielles ne sommes pas
plus craindre les pressions de la france
et ses demandes de mettre fin à la
répression qu'une hypothétique enquête
internationale commentaires 1 h avant le
club de londres regroupe les créanciers
privés les banques d'un pays en
l'occurrence la russie
ces banques se moque de la tchétchénie
comme de leur premier chèque
seule leur importe de récupérer leur
argent en renonçant à 36 % de la dette
russe
j'espère donc encaissé à terme les 64 %
restants et tant pis pour les
tchétchènes
il en va différemment bien sûr des états
regroupés au sein d'un autre club le
club de paris eux aussi ont des créances
sur la russie 75 milliards de dollars
des créances qui pourrait être un moyen
de pression car après tout la russie
n'est pas si pauvre elle a dégagé l'an
dernier un excédent commercial de 30
milliards de dollars dont on ne peut
s'empêcher de penser qu'il finance en ce
moment la guerre en tchétchénie exercer
ce genre de pression c'est donc une
question de volonté politique et c'est
là que le bât blesse
si les images de tchétchénie choc le
public
les réactions des gouvernements reste
verbale ce matin encore celle d'hubert
védrine ou encore strictement symbolique
comme les mesures prises par l'union
européenne
bombardements massacre quand tout cela
n'enlève rien à l'importance stratégique
de la russie
incontournable partenaire d'un occident
qui ne veut à aucun prix retourner à la
guerre froide et qui veut en revanche à
tout prix éviter un effondrement
chaotique de ce pays
alors on prend contact avec le nouveau
chef du kremlin vladimir poutine
la plupart des ministres des affaires
étrangères ont déjà défilé à moscou et
ont pris que la page tchétchène et ses
horreurs soit tourné le plus vite
possible que l'on puisse continuer à
faire de la realpolitik sans mauvaise
conscience
et puis en tchétchénie il y a toujours
un otage français brice fleutiaux
photographe indépendant retenu depuis le
1er octobre 1999
bill clinton le président américain
d'autre part affirmé que l'on pouvait
s'entendre avec delà des meilleures
poutines qualifié par lui de dirigeant
très fort efficace et dire et cette
affirmation du président des états unis
fait partie d'une interview accordée sur
internet à la chaîne cnn c'est une
première du genre
à noter qu'au cours de cet entretien sur
le net quelques pirates informatiques se
sont introduits en provoquant un chahut
avec quelques interrogations plutôt
légères pour contrer les pirates du web
la maison blanche a proposé mardi aux
grands acteurs de l'industrie
informatique réuni autour du président
clinton grands acteurs des réseaux
également de participer à la création
d'un centre pour la sécurité internet et
de partager leurs contre-mesures car
l'honnêteté perméable et c'est bien
cette impression qui semble retenir les
français pour utiliser les services en
ligne de leurs banques
actuellement il y a plus ou moins neuf
cent mille français qui utilisent les
services bancaires via internet soit 17
% des internautes de notre pays
on est bien loin de la pratique anglaise
par exemple explications avec laurence
griffon juliette beau et vincent
ferreira la façade est anonyme et
pourtant c'est ici à londres que s'est
installé l'un des leaders européens de
la banque sur internet
après un an d'existence il a déjà dans
ses caisses près de 70 milliards de
francs de dépens ce résultat fait
saliver plus d'une banque française mais
dans l'hexagone le marché est beaucoup
moins développé avec 125 mille abonnés
la baisse est largement en tête mais
elle compte sept fois moins de clients
que son homologue britannique en fait
les services commerciaux de la banque on
vous multipliez les efforts la majorité
des internautes craignent le piratage de
leur compte
le banquier lui le rassurer lorsque vous
êtes chez vous vous essayez d'avoir une
serrure d'avancé sur les cambrioleurs eh
bien nous nous faisons la même chose
nous investissons en permanence pour
avoir le meilleur niveau de sécurité et
nous testons régulièrement et on nous
maintenant ce haut niveau de sécurité
pour maintenir ce niveau des entreprises
comme celle ci spécialisée dans la
sécurisation constamment ils doivent se
réadapter nouvelles formes de piratage
constamment elle se heurte à une
évidence le risque zéro n'existe pas on
essaye de réduire le risque et on essaye
de faire en sorte que ce soit de plus en
plus fiables mais en aucun cas on sait
l'interdire complètement la stratégie
des banques encourager les clients à se
jeter à l'eau déjà 7 millions de
français gèrent leur pente à distance
via le minitel ou le téléphone internet
représenterait donc un nouveau service
avec ses risques comme partout tu ailles
la fraude sur internet et pas supérieur
à la fraude qu'on peut constater chez
les vépécistes classiques tels que la
redoute ou les 3 suisses ou par le biais
du téléphone ou par le biais du minitel
internet sans danger un message que les
banquiers vont marteler les prochains
mois pour convaincre leurs clients
d'abandonner le guichet au profit de la
souris du sport du football avec de
mauvaises nouvelles venues de l'italie
le calcio connaît des provocations
racistes dans les stades italiens
notamment celui de la lazio de rome les
footballeurs noirs doivent supporter les
comportements racistes de la part de
supporters revendiquant quelques idées
fascistes ainsi lilian thuram de parme a
été conspué dimanche dernier le
président de la lazio de rome menace de
jouer le prochain match à huit clos si
cela se reproduit reportage de nos
correspondants à rome isabelle staes et
dominique merlet c'est de cette tribune
le virage nord réservé aux plus excités
des tifosi italiens que fuse injures
racistes et slogans fascistes à rome ce
dimanche 13 février
c'est sous haute protection policière
que doit se dérouler le match lazio
parme
les fouilles et l'inspection des
banderoles sont minutieuse afin de
prévenir tout dérapage propagande
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est totalement
excessifs qui n'est pas autorisé c'est
l'affichage des croix celtiques et des
croix gammées a comme on nous en
interdisant l'entrée
ce soir là pourtant thuram et deux
autres joueurs de tarn sont devenus les
boucs émissaires du racisme dans le
football italien
ils ont joué sous les huées des
extrémistes de la lazio
on les appelle les irréductibles
coutumier des slogans racistes et autres
dérapages qui ont valu au club 600 mille
francs d'amendé la saison dernière et
une image déplorable et c'est un
comportement qui doit cesser et si ce
comportement ne s'améliore pas nous
jouerons à huis clos car les
irréductibles n'ont pas de limite dans
l'intolérable
ainsi le 30 janvier lors du match lazio
baril des banderoles à la gloire
d'arcane le criminel de guerre serbe
côtoyaient un portrait du mussolini et
des croix celtique s'ils ne sont qu'une
minorité a affiché ainsi leur extrémisme
le football leur offre pourtant une
véritable caisse de résonance il ya tout
un virage du stade qui est entièrement
dans les mains de l'extrême droite à
connotation fasciste néonazis et
fortement racisme ainsi dans les stades
ils font du prosélytisme politique et
ils trouvent un espace de propagande
dans la ville face à cette dérive
fasciste dans les stades
le gouvernement italien menace de
suspendre les matches en cas de nouveaux
dérapages
voilà du sport du vrai aussi avec une
cérémonie c'était cet après midi au
siège de france télévisions afin
d'honorer des joueurs de l'équipe de
france de rugby c'était les oscars du
midi olympique famille pour nous faille
dans marc tessier avec médaille d'or à
fabien pelous argent et christophe
dominici bronze vous le voyez emile
ntamack
et puis les entraîneurs argent à bernard
laporte en caisse à ses petites lunettes
et or à guy novès du si demain du cinéma
demain vous pourrez voir un film
d'ettore scola le dîner c'est une soirée
particulière dans un restaurant une
trattoria ou peu à peu à chaque table
autour de chaque client vont se nouer
des histoires des petits drames des
comédies des larmes et beaucoup de rires
tout cela sous l'oeil de vittorio
gassman et de la patronne du restaurant
fanny ardant nous retrouvons dans un
instant
présentation de ce film du dîner avec
nicolas cornu d'anglo et gibert usant
nous l'avons tant aimé le cinéma
d'ettore scola que le retrouver fait
renaître plein de souvenirs de comédie
tendre et satirique les affreux sales et
méchants et les acteurs fabuleux qui
fréquentait aussi ce même bar de palace
car les italiens aiment la convivialité
la chaleur de ces lieux de rencontre
comme ce restaurant tenu par fagnard
dans des fosses la monnaie et le sens du
temps nice et de temps unité de lieu du
dîner comme dans le bal la terrasse
comme cessionnaire j selke et je des
droits qu'ils soient restés sans télé
avec eux vous le permet c'est juste war
et le solaire
c'est aussi un endroit où l'on peut
séduire rompre se disputait ce charme et
observer ce que fais tu aurais scola qui
cultive la nostalgie en mettant ses amis
de toujours en phase de ses actrices
préférées pour des destins qui se
croisent peut pas inventer
on peut les changer on peut le présenter
selon une source rebelle mais c'était
pas qu'il manie adam est en plateau là
qu'est ce que vous auriez une ligne que
je suis très content de faire ce métier
que ce métier m'a permis de connaître si
j'aurais fermé t'es peut-être que jamais
comme nous donc je suis content de mes
tracés
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
maintenant mais si j'avais tenir un
salon de coiffure j'espère qu'ils
seraient rentrés ou si je vais tenir
confiserie serait rentré aussi ou des
cigarettes ou une trattoria nous avons
et chaussures rouges qui brille fonds
mam
c'était d'être dans cette maison en
effet on l'a tourné près cinecitta
c'était comme il a été dit dans le sujet
unité de temps unité lieu unité d'action
et c'est magnifique de se dire au revoir
et demain je pouvais enfin ça fait
beaucoup penser à ce qui les fait déjà
avec le bas c'est à dire qu'il ya des
scieries d'histoire d'un huis clos mais
il ya des séries d'histoire des séries
comédie à des petits drames et des
moments très violent je pense que c'est
comme une sorte de deux mondes au
microscope
avec cette possibilité que chaque membre
peut rebondir sur l'autre c'est comme
dans tous les lieux clos c'est cette
façon de vivre
on sait pas ce qui va se passer
peut-être que la table d'à côté va
intervenir peut-être que non de toute
façon les conversations vont se
avoir un lien entre elles pour montrer
une forme d'humanité que la m ça va très
vite dans le film iron tour l'impression
que tous les tous les passagers de ce
restaurant se dire ceux qui sont là par
son hyper hazard rêve chacun d'être
quelque chose et qui se raconte
rés et tout cela et vittorio gassman qui
met son petit mot par ci par là
oui comme le choeur antique qu'ils
voient tous qui fait tout ce qui sent
tout est donc ce côté cette part de rêve
qu'on a tous en ce que bon une vie n'est
pas assez alors se dire qu'à celle qu'on
vit est celle qu'on aurait voulu dire
c'est ce qui fait la grandeur de chaque
être humain c'est que il ya ce côté très
prosaïque de la condition humaine
mais elle rêve c'est ce qui rend
quelques fois heureux à quelques fois
mais là je sais de ne pas beaucoup la
télévision actualité vous êtes très
contemplatif vous aimez bien écouter
participer à des conversations dans ce
rôle d'hôtesse du restaurant vous êtes
bien retrouver comme quelqu'un qui
justement essai de suisse tous ces
drames tous et tous serrés
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans ce rôle c'est
cette personne cette femme qui accueille
des gens pour que pendant deux heures
ces personnes soient heureuses soit bien
c'est pas beaucoup d heures
mais déjà de se dire pendant deux heures
de la vie de quelqu'un je lui aurais
alléger les soucis les problèmes donc
j'adorais ce personnage de femme douche
femme lumineuse qui voit tout mais qui
ne se mêlent pas trop ça m'a plu vous
aviez déjà joué sous sa direction
oui c'est la famille c'est ça oui me
souviens c'était un chien même principe
tout se passait dans un appartement et
sa recouvrait toute la vie du siècle et
c'est surtout pas une pièce de théâtre
filmé un c'est vraiment dans le film
d'action vous avez beaucoup d'action
mais quelques grammes sont prises et
violent quelquefois de huy lê thanh
italienne acqua désarment italiens qui
les font devenir français c'est pas ça
non mais ce qu'il ya de bien dans le
film des torres et que vous regardez une
table mais toujours dans l'arrière fond
est ce qu'on continue quelque chose
c'est ça dans le cinéma c'est que vous
êtes le premier plan mais les arrières
fonds sont très importants si il ya un
vrai discours politique comme d'habitude
d'ailleurs chez et aux risques large
élevé dans nous sommes tentés mais il y
avait cette fois nous voulions changer
le monde et on s'est pas rendu compte
que
le monde qui nous a changé et là il ya
plusieurs de ses passagers se disait de
ses clients du restaurant qui
effectivement eu un moment envie de
changer le monde et puis l'âge le temps
les réflexions les confrontations ont
changé et puis ce que dit bien être et
dans le petit sujet avant c'est que les
gens ne se parlent plus donc à ce
malentendu qui s'installe peut-être
entre parents enfants employés patrons
d'une même entreprise tout le monde avec
son petit téléphone
ce malentendu entre les amants et les
maîtresses des malentendus c'est luis
scola avec sa baguette magique pendant
deux heures il va donner cette
possibilité que les gens vont enfin dire
la pierre dure que chacun en soit en
tout d'un coup c'est quand même un petit
drame qui va se passer
quelquefois tout va bien et quelquefois
bon mais subit vous comme nous tous on
vit de plein de petits malentendus de
petites choses puis on marange son
organisme oui oui moi je pense toujours
que quand on voit justement le film de
scola ça donne envie de vivre parce
qu'on se dit au fond c'est moi c'est pas
grand chose mais c'est moi et ça me
donne envie de vivre avec le peuple je
suis c'est quand même une vision assez
pessimiste non tout est pas pas
pessimiste vrai donc comme si ce n'est
pas comme ça tout le monde rigole tout
le monde rigole mais c'est une vision
vrai où on décide de rire plutôt que de
pleurer mais il ya cette chose de dire
dont allait allonger vous êtes
pessimiste vous avez une vision graves
des choses où justement voulez vous
mettre en retrait de des choses de
l'actualité parce qu'on est grand de
tous les soins non moi je suis quelqu'un
d'assez pessimiste mais j'ai toujours ce
qu pts et incurable de dire mais demain
est un nouveau jour
mais si je voulais pas baisser les armes
mais ma vision n'est pas optimiste mais
ça ne s'est pas pour ça qu'il faut pas
continuer à dire qu'il ya quelque chose
à conquérir vous dites juillet même si
ça sert à rien
ce côté comme se dire bon allez j'y vais
j'y vais passer mon seul façon ma seule
façon de vivre finalement on va rien
changer mais un par un par un il y avait
cette étincelle de dire bon j'y vais ça
ses moteurs en fait oui merci beaucoup
c'est bien et puis je voudrais dire
bonne chance au réalisateur français
régis wargnier qui figure avec le film
est ouest sur la liste finale des 5
films nominés pour les oscars dans la
catégorie du meilleur film étranger sur
cette liste figurent également tout sur
ma mère de pedro almodovar régis vernis
qui a déjà remporté le coup c'était en
92 un oscar avec indochine
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de cette
édition je vous rappel l'activité
concernant les manifestations contre la
carte scolaire syrie manifestation grave
de parents d'élèves de personnel
enseignant perspective du changement la
carte scolaire pour la rentrée 2000 les
mouvements les plus importants ont eu
lieu dans le département du gard et dans
celui de l'hérault et puis en football
actuellement le fc nantes mène devant
lyon si lui un tibia me dire du sipri la
météo c'est dans quelques secondes avec
isabelle martinet isabelle martinet
22h45 la vie à l'endroit présente est
admiré dumas avec pour thème les
plaisirs du palais retranscrit les
dîners voilier et puis à 0 heures 25 le
journal de la nuit qui sera présentée
par thierry thulliez demain 750 dans les
4 vérités gérard morin recevra nicole
fontaine le président du parlement
européen
pauvre ici même carte bester et rachid
arhab à 13h à demain 20 heures dont soir
tous